i would see that they're reading the
email and not answering and i'm like you
know
what's happening here i mean couldn't
you just click reply
and say no
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders it's so great to have you
thanks for having me where are you
calling from from the from israel right
now
i'm in israel in the small place called
respond which is just outside of tel
aviv
next to the beach yep can't complain
wonderful wonderful
amazing and so you know you're one of
the most prominent investors in israel
and i'm
gonna allow myself not to be humble at
this point you can be humble later on
and but you know from from an amazing
time as a ceo of 888 holdings to
an incredible angel investor family man
board of directors of
some incredible non-profits that are
doing some really noteworthy
work in israel and abroad
i'd love to spend these 20 minutes just
to you know pick your brain
on who are you and how do you find these
incredible opportunities how do you go
about investing in a seed stage company
in
in people rather than you know just look
at matrix and ideas
can you just give me a little bit of a
start about what's your biggest passion
and what really motivates you
well um so i think there's uh
you know at the end of the day um
i think that what i really enjoy doing
is working with amazing people
uh i'm a people's person and uh
not working with people is difficult for
me and so whatever i do
you know when i founded companies when i
was a ceo when i was in the military
uh it was always in roles that i could
surround myself with amazing people
and i think that when i left my last co
position
which was uh i don't know nine ten years
ago
and i i started thinking what i want to
do with the rest of my time
and i was just about to take another
another ceo position but
what occurred to me is that what i
really liked about
being the ceo was working with people on
product
on strategy on solving issues on and
what i
really didn't like is working on how
many vacation days people are getting
and who's getting a salary raise or not
and uh
yeah and you know and what and doing all
these other things including investor
relations because the last
job was a public company and i really
didn't like that and so i said
maybe i can find a job that has only the
things that i like
without the things i don't like and
basically investing in early stage
startup is just that
it is the perfect combination for me
because i spend
as long as the founders want me to i
spend time with them
on everything that i love and everywhere
where i can bring value
and you know thank god i'm still close
to to being operational enough to be
able to bring some value
uh but i don't deal with everyday
company management
i love that so you're a very active
investor you form a partnership with
with your founders and you enjoy working
with them beyond just the the noticeable
check size that you provide them
so i think that i've invested over the
years you know as an agent i invested in
more than 120 companies
over over many years yeah over many
years over
16 years now i started when i was you
know when i was still having a day job
and this was like a hobby like everybody
else does and so 120 companies and then
we've had an accelerator for a period of
time so that was another 80 and then in
the fund we invested in like more than
40.
and so i've touched many entrepreneurs
and
and i think that my biggest pride is
that i think that
all of them other than really a handful
are people that i would invest in again
are people that i that i enjoyed working
with
and are people that are uh are really
amazing
uh individuals that ended up being also
friends
and and so what you know the one of the
biggest difference
and you know we're we're a fund that's
been set up by three
founders you know pete james and me and
uh
and i think one of the biggest
differences between us and other funds
or
not you know they're also other great
funds one of the biggest differences is
that
we remember you know what being a
founder is like
and you'd never hear us say things like
uh
my company like when i talk about a
company where i invested in you know
we don't think that by giving the
company money it became our company
you know we are we're lucky to be able
to join the journey
of entrepreneurs and help as much as we
can hopefully
but that doesn't make it our company and
that doesn't make it in any way
um it doesn't give us the right to think
that because we gave money we called the
shots it is the founders company
the you know the founders are in the
trenches they're the ones not sleeping
at night there's the one
working 27 hours a day um we're just
joining the ride and trying
to help as much as we can and so yes we
have a very deep partnership with the
founders
many times people ask me uh you know do
you insist to be on the board and i say
look i don't insist on being on the
board
but i do insist on being the last
meeting before the board
meaning i want to be that person that is
on the side of the founders close to the
founders so that before they decide how
they present things
uh they come to me and say what do you
think and that's the kind of
relationship where we have
the founders we invest in and just to
give a bit of context in another
interview i saw that you mentioned that
you're you're seeing
you know about 2 000 deals a year out of
those you
have invested in a specific year in
about seven so you really do
pick the founders that you get to work
with and it's not just writing a check
to any nice person that comes by the
door
but it's more than that i also mentioned
something along the lines of
we invent when we look at an opportunity
we look at seventy percent
the the people twenty percent of the
field and ten percent of the idea
yes what does that mean seventy percent
of the people so
yeah so so the first thing i think that
what people need to understand
is that the earlier you invest the more
weight you give to the people
right if you're investing in uh you know
in a growth round where the company is
already making
50 million dollar revenues and you can
see the churn and you can see exactly
then
at the end of the day clearly you also
want to be in love with the with the
founding team and the management team
but in a way a company that sells 50
million
maybe there's another ceo that can also
do the job if the founder decides to
leave or something so
you're basically putting a lot of a lot
of focus on the product of the numbers
on what's
really working and not working and then
there's of course
a bit to the people or you know less to
the people
if you go pre-seed if you go all the way
to the beginning when you invest in a
bunch of people
sometimes one or two people with the
deck sometimes there's not even a deck
sometimes the deck is horrible
when you invest in them then most of the
weight you're putting is on the people
and when i tried to quantify it i looked
back so i was asked this question first
time i think like six or seven years ago
and so i said could i
try to create an algorithm that
basically tells me
uh what what to do and i'll get back to
this in a second because we have created
this
um and i try to understand what was my
guiding lines and so
the reality is that i say it's 70
percent to the people because that's the
most important thing at seat stage 20
to the field and 10 to the idea however
there's a bunch of disclaimers around it
the first disclaimer is that uh
they're fields that i don't invest in
and so while it's only 20
it's binary so you know yes the field
impacts if it's one of the fields i
invest in i give 20 percent
but if it's for example semiconductors
that we don't invest in
then clearly that's binary similarly
with the idea
the idea is if it's the right team in
the right field
i really don't care about the idea too
much because that's going to change
gazillion times next week however if the
idea is really bad
that kind of impacts my analysis of the
team right if they came with a really
really bad idea
then it impacts and so it is really a
bit more balanced but
reality is that most of our decision
making at the early stage is
a lot around the team okay so between us
and between the
the couple a thousand others that are
going to watch this out of the
120 angel investments plus 40 with the
fund
how many do you feel like you've had a
personal impact
on the journey of the founder a positive
impact
an honest question yeah so i think that
um
clearly i need to be careful here
because
uh my my explanation to myself of the
hard work that i'm putting in has got to
be
conditioned on me believing that i'm
making an impact and so
clearly i'm biased and i think that i
made a
you know tremendous impact on everybody
i think that but but realistically but
realistically i think that
in every company that i've invested in
there has been a bunch of
points where clearly they could have
gotten maybe the same advice from
somebody else smarter than me or they me
but i think there were a couple of
points where
me being there at the right time with
the right answer
save them time or save them money or got
them to the right place now
there are areas where you know there are
companies where
i don't know we sold the company for 700
million dollars i brought the buyer
i negotiated the deal i closed the door
and so that's very that's very tangible
but i think that actually the the most
important ones are the ones where um
that are not around the you know me
being involved in the big success it's
me
being involved in the tough times me
being in the late night falls and
you know somebody leaving and
everybody's broken or the product's not
working and you need to
reiterate again and again and again and
you need somebody to
kind of look you in the eyes and tell
you that this is what's happening to
everybody
and that's okay and you know you
shouldn't break or you know or these
times where
uh you know somebody's come to you and
he just doesn't want to continue doing
what he's doing because you know because
it's so tiring and so difficult
and you give them an honest analysis of
why they should
or sometimes why they shouldn't i think
that you know one of the one of the
things i'm most proud of is that
i think that every once in a while i run
into somebody that
that comes to me and tells me you know
you saved me three four years of my life
and i owe you for that
a lot more than i owe the people that uh
they told me to continue or the people
that
because sometimes you know you from
where you sit you see things
differently and you know that um that
something's not going to work or you
know that something is in the
wrong direction or you know competition
and you know it's way ahead
in a way that's going to be tough to
catch up i think that at the end of the
day
a lot of the advice that i give people
is um it's not necessarily
on huge things you know what what i
found over the years is that
uh yes of course every once in a while
there's a big strategy session and i can
help in that and every you know that's
great
but the reality is that uh a lot of it
is on the small things
and so you know a founder decides to
that he needs to let go of somebody
and he's never done that before he's
never done he never let go anybody in
the united states or he's never done
this or that
and these things are you know you can
either now spend a month on
understanding how to do it or you can
ask somebody that saw it in many places
or did it before
um or you know you need to sign an
agreement with an affiliate you've never
done that before you don't know what to
do and so
these are the kind of things that that i
think many times the relationship are
very
around uh kind of very practically
uh it could be like whatsapp's in the
middle of the night i was gonna ask
do you have two minutes is it is it a
whatsapp message or is it a
weekly meeting a phone call email
so i think that uh it's the combination
it's all of the above and it's a
combination
and the reality is that usually with
most companies i have
like a weekly call or sometimes if
there's the frequency does not require
that maybe every two weeks
yeah but then there would be emails and
there would be
uh whatsapp so there would be you know
messengers and messages and so on
and everybody would kind of ping me at
the right moment
and i try to keep time in my calendar to
basically get back to everybody
uh because many you know if the point is
that a lot of this advice is very timely
and so
if you can't if you can't give the
answer now
then the answer is not that valuable
because
the founder already had to go to others
and ask questions and consult the
lawyers and
and so on um and you know also if you
need to make a product decision you know
if they want to ask you something about
new design
you can't give them the answer in three
days the sprint's already over
okay but gigi hold on you've you're
invested in over a hundred companies
you're still running
a fund and you're actively looking at
thousands of of the of opportunities per
year
how do you make time to answer people i
mean literally how tangibly do you make
the time to go and answer once
so first of all i think that i work more
than i ever thought i'm going to work as
a as an investor
that's a reality for all of you out
there that thing that investor life
is is kind of going to the beach every
day uh
you may have the option to go to the
beach every day because theoretically
nobody tells you what to do but
actually that doesn't it'll take them
about five years to realize that you
haven't done much yeah
yeah exactly and so uh you know i i work
more than i ever did that's one thing
the second thing is that
uh i'm a very very very uh efficient and
effective
uh time manager yep so my days are very
very
tight i work like very high energy
throughout the day and then
many of the nights sadly uh and that's
that and
and i think that um i'll tell you a
story many years ago when i started my
first company
actually my second company uh and um
i was after being an air force pilot and
i was used to this ecosystem where
basically people respond to each other
you know you're like
you have a question you ask somebody the
answer and i remember trying to sell my
product
many years ago and i would send emails
to people
and they would not reply and
and i would then you know back then you
could still put a bit of java code into
the email
that uh that allowed you to know that
people actually open it and read it
and so i would see that they're reading
the email and not answering and i'm like
you know what's happening here i mean
couldn't you just click reply
and say no yeah or if you want to be
nasty click reply and say
never write me again but something and
nothing and i took it i took a
commitment that doesn't matter who i am
and how successful i am that's never
going to happen to people writing me
so everybody writing me always gets uh
gets a reply
i try to make it uh very fast i'm kind
of an inbox zero person but it's
but it's difficult sometimes uh and
um and that's a commitment that takes a
lot of my time but it's also
you know it's also a lot of a lot of the
uh energy that i give back into the
ecosystem or i try to give back
and also i mean let's be frank every uh
you know every company that
that asks me a question or every uh new
business plan i look
at a deck it's not just
for the benefit of those that i'm
replying to i'm also learning from it
right so every day i read i look at the
deck and i say wow that's interesting i
didn't know that this business is so
large i didn't know that
that these are the competitors in this
field i didn't know that there is a new
way to do something and so
i'm trying to learn from everything and
um
and so yeah it's a lot of work do you
have a systematic approach of how you
how you appreciate the deal flow that
you have so let's say you have
a few hundred deals per month is there a
certain way in which you approach these
deals or is it our cake based on the
industry and the way the founders are
communicating with you
mean how do i appreciate it how do i
evaluate how do you how do you judge
how do i evaluate it so ah so
so i'll there's basically two things the
first thing is that for years now what
i'm doing is that i'm reading everything
and then
i start what i call the email ping pong
which is basically
playing email table tennis with the
founders and asking questions
um these questions basically i look
they save me time from having meetings
but they also allow me to see
how good the founders deal with
questions deal with hard questions
are these binary questions of will i
will they make it sort of to the next
round for a meeting or not or are they
more
none of them are questions that like you
know there's no cheat sheet that people
are sending around gig is asking you
these questions
but it's um i i am looking and i'm
saying okay let you know it could be
around competition could be around
product could be around team could be
around anything else
and basically what uh what i'm saying is
not just
uh not just what they say but also how
they say it
right and how fast they say it and how
do they take criticism
and how do they take doubt and how do
they take the harder questions
that indicate that i'm maybe not as
impressed as they would like me to be
yeah and you'd be shocked how much you
can find out from these things and so
you know
and if somebody i mean let's face the
reality if i send if i if somebody sends
me a deck
and i send them a few questions and he
takes him now four or five days to get
back to me
and he doesn't have a good answer like
in a story i was you know i was in
military service or something
then i mean if he takes he if if he
takes four or five
uh days to get back to me how long would
it take him
to get back to a customer would it take
him to get back to a candidate
how long would it take him to get back
to an investor another investor
right right and so in the seed round
you're also thinking about the future
rounds and how can you get more exactly
so
i learned from that then so for like
from every 10 companies that i get
there would be probably like four or
five that are either in field that i
totally don't invest in or competing
with something that i'm already
investing in so let's say that
half of them i can disqualify very
quickly
then there's going to be around another
three that
um that will be disqualified in the
ping-pong once i understand the business
better and i see
and then for every 10 there's like two
that i end up meeting
okay and being that i'm getting around
probably
i don't know almost 10 every day every
workday
then that ends up being around i don't
know 30 40 meetings
a month that usually end up being less
than one
investment a month so it's a pretty
crazy flow that's that's pretty pretty
crazy
iggy and you know just a minute or two
because we're almost out of time and i'm
and i'm so sad about it
talk to me about covet 19 we're almost
you know it looks like we're we're
starting to see the light at the end of
the tunnel by the time this interview is
published hopefully
it's much much better than it already is
right now
fast track nfx you did something that's
very contrarian to a lot of other funds
around the world
talk to me about that so i think that uh
we started seeing that with kova
everybody was kind of retracting and not
investing anymore or investing less
and clearly by the way the best teams
and the best geos continued raising
money that's good but there's everybody
else that
also needs to raise money and grow and
we looked at it and we said that
um it's either that we like everybody
else kind of say well wait and see
or we try to challenge the industry and
actually do what we think is the right
thing
which is actually to invest more in seed
at this stage why because
seed companies are basically companies
that are going to work now for
a few months on their product they're
not dependent on the current recession
or non-recession it's the best time to
be heads down working and
and working on your product and
basically the innovation
economy does not need to stop it is the
future that's the future and we need to
continue fueling it and we have uh
you know we have money we've been given
money by our lp's to invest it for not
to sit on it
and so we said let's do something which
is exactly the opposite so when
everybody else was saying
we're slowing down we said we're
accelerating what did we do we took
all the capabilities that we had before
which are products that we built like
the company brief which allows us to get
structured data
it allows everybody to send data about
their company to investors
and so we told everybody if you're
submitting a company brief to us
and you're and you're looking at the
investment docs that we put out because
we don't want any negotiations on the
document these are standard safe
documents
and they're completely um standard and
you can read them beforehand
and you know exactly what's going to be
the valuation you know exactly what's
going to be the percentage we're taking
so that depending on your state it was
always fifteen percent
for one million one and a half million
or two million then we promised
initial feedback in three days and a
decision in nine days
wow and um i we're not saying exactly
how much we got but i can tell you that
it's in the thousands wow and i can tell
you yeah and i can tell you that
basically um we are
uh we're lucky to have built a very
robust system uh technological system
that basically helps us digest
everything
and so every deal that comes in is being
ranked by our uh
by algorithms it doesn't mean that
there's we never say no
without a human watching it so you know
we this is not an automated business
this is a decision support system more
than anything else
however we are uh we're clearly
uh and you know ripping right now we're
enjoying the the
the fruits of the hard work we've done
over the last few years because
every company that comes in now i know
exactly what to look at i know exactly
what are
the things that i need to pay attention
to um and so
you know and then that also allows us to
write more detailed
uh rejection emails to those that we
reject uh or to ask the right questions
to the one we want to continue with and
uh and so far we've made a few
investments and we love it
wow okay so giggy so once an
entrepreneur always an entrepreneur
that obviously comes across and and you
know i had so many things i wanted to
talk about your experience as an air
force pilot and
comparing that to some of the things
that you're experiencing as a founder
and an investor and a bit about
who you are as a person and the things
that really really make you passionate
but
one thing that i have to say that i'm
hugely inspired by is the high energy
and that's something that i've i'm
trying to practice myself and trying to
learn how can i bring the highest energy
to my work ethic and to the meetings
that i hold and to really
maximize the time that i'm working with
people and and providing value and
knowing to
put myself to put myself away from the
position where i don't add value
which is i think often one of the
hardest things you know at the end of
the day a lot of it is about being
truthful to yourself
you know what most people what many
people do is that they
uh they take something upon themselves
or they they're in the meeting or
something and they're not giving
everything
you know they're reading emails they're
thinking about something
else which is fine everybody has these
moments however
if you want to be truthful to yourself
then
when you are in something you need to be
100 in it
i love it and if you can't be 100 then
you're probably in the wrong place and
find a better place for yourself i love
it i know you're so busy enough to let
you go but
very last question i need three words
that best describe you
yeah so you know i think that at the end
of the day
a more interesting exercise is like a
sentence that describes three words is
like very
uh but if i um
you know if i you gave me like you gave
me like a 20 minutes heads up that i
need to come up with
that's nearly enough yeah yeah but i
think that if i uh
this is something that i've been
thinking a lot about my you know about
myself about my life about being a
parent about my kids
um and you know kind of the the three
values
at the end of the day that i think that
uh
that i that have if i had to choose what
would be
the ones that i would love to to use to
define myself
uh the three are love passion and care
these are the three and i think that you
know all three of them
in a way do not sound like uh
like business related ones but they are
the core
of every business success it's love it's
love
passion and care and i think that if i
then had
you know if i had the chance to to add
a couple more one of them would be
learning and the other one would be
speed
right which are more kind of concrete to
uh to the business rule but love passion
and care
definitely the ones that i think would
love to think are defining me
gigi thank you so so much for the
inspiration thank you thanks for having
me your friendship
and take care this this is wonderful
thank you great
bye okay
you